so coming out of the Spider-Man video
you guys have been asking how it was the
Franklin Richards lost his powers here's
what happened so in Marvel Comics
Franklin losing his powers takes place
over the course of like three different
story arcs you have the end of Secret
Wars 2015 you have the X-Men Fantastic
Four crossover in 2020 and then you have
Fantastic Four volume six issue number
25 by Dan slot the way this worked out
is that at the end of Secret Wars 2015
Franklin Richards power which we thought
was Limitless started to dwindle and the
reason why is because he alongside the
molecule man Owen Reese and his father
Reed Richards were basically restoring
the entirety of the Multiverse with
Franklin Richards literally recreating
every single Universe by hand now when
the Fantastic Four came back in Marvel
Comics that's when we learned Franklin's
Powers had been steadily decreasing over
time because of the amount of power he
was using in order to recreate the
Multiverse now this goes into the X-Men
Fantastic Four crossover which saw two
things happening for Franklin the first
was that Dr Doom had basically
discovered something called the god gene
or the God particle but in effect the
ability for Franklin Richards powers to
be restored and then to actually allow
him to tap into the power of the one
above all which would make him
drastically more powerful than he had
ever been before such as it was a fight
broke out between the X-Men and the
Fantastic Four due to the fact that with
Franklin Richards having always been a
mutant in Marvel Comics and its powers
disappearing the X-Men wanted to bring
him to the mutant nation of krakowa in
order to find a way to restore his
powers as opposed to leaving it to Dr
Doom who's always doing stuff for
nefarious purposes now for those of you
guys who are unfamiliar with what this
means in Marvel Comics right now the
X-Men live over in krakowa that is to
say an island out in the middle of
nowhere the only way to access krakowa
is by getting in and out through
krakowan Gates and the only way to pass
through those Gates is to have an X Gene
and so were Franklin Richards for a Time
lived among the mutant population he
ended up returning to the Fantastic Four
but because there didn't seem to be a
way to return his powers back to normal
this goes into Fantastic Four volume six
issue number 25 by Dan slot and what we
ended up finding out here is there is a
being out there called the cremornan who
answers to a guy called the Helmsman but
the komoran is on Earth for the purpose
of basically finding some kind of an
artifact he never actually finds it but
he does end up in a fight with a
Fantastic Four specifically Franklin
Richards the reason for this is because
Dr Doom had realized how powerful the
Kimora was and after talking to Reed
Richards the two of them agreed Franklin
was the only person on Earth with enough
power to defeat the Khmer and so
Franklin Richards goes into the battle
he charges up every ounce of energy he
has left he goes to land a punch and he
hits the guy but it's not enough to
destroy him and Franklin Richards is
basically powerless and so following
that he ends up traveling to one of the
krakowan gates to try to find his way
through and he can't pass this is when
Professor Xavier appears and then
basically reveals that Franklin Richards
ability to alter reality had actually
allowed him to subconsciously alter his
genes to turn him into a mutant and that
with his powers gone his genes go back
to normal meaning he's just a normal guy
and so his ability to join mutant's
Uncle KOA is officially rejected and
that's where he's been in Marvel Comics
ever since with that being said we're
gonna bring this video to an end
hopefully it answered your question
thank you for watching and I will catch
you all later peace